one thing i was thinking about this
morning is we now have a new
vice president yeah we'll be sworn in
soon kamala harris yes
you do uh a a very good uh kamala
impression yes and you know i do have a
kamala harris impression and
the key to it is actually sounding like
you just left happy hour
because because i'm lit i am so lit
i am so lit like when she was when she
was walking
that morning and she called up joe biden
yeah hi
joe you won we did
it i was like yo she just had a picture
of bloody mary's that's what happened
like she had to walk so she could walk
off the bloody marys that's how it works
literally man she just sounds turnt
she's she's turt she looks good
she's blendy and it all works out yeah
yeah i like it i like black and indian
blending
you're uh did i hear correctly that you
are working
on a uh a new impression joaquin
phoenix's joker is that right i am now
what is the key to doing
joaquin phoenix's joker totally losing
your mind um
eating uh eating an apple a day no no
you don't have to do that don't
please don't do the joaquin phoenix diet
you will not live okay yeah
he's different all right he's not from
here that was scary skinny
he was yo you could literally see his
heart from his backbone
like it was so crazy but he was
translucent yeah
you could see through him because he was
so he was
the key to it though conan is
you know basically you have to switch
your voice
and talk like this it's not hard they
just think we'll just sit there
that we won't werewolf and go wild we'll
just take it like good little boys
you think guys like thomas wayne care
about people like me
they don't you know that means so and
the key to it like i'm saying another
key
always stay in character in my house so
i'm in house
doing things as wyoking phoenix you know
washing dishes um
cooking intercourse whatever you need
know what i mean
i mean that's i mean that's wild though
you know why i can't fix some girls like
it you know what i mean it'd be like
yeah hit the yeah hit me with your
impression i'm like you like that
don't you oh my god is that why keen yes
it is and i've been bad but you've been
more bad naughty
[Laughter]
also stops you from climaxing if you
need you know you can always
you can always pull that out it stopped
me right there yeah
i was ready to go yo can i tell you this
once i really did this with my
ex-girlfriend right
you know it was a little too great and
um
it was a little too good and um i was
like yo you gotta slow down yeah i mean
but you know women don't
listen sometimes right we do people
people don't listen exactly
exactly men and women both men and women
but
she ain't want to listen so i had to
pull out the jay-z real quick and i
laughed and then that made her stop
you know what i mean you do with jay-z
laughing that makes everything stop that
makes everything stop
like she i was like yo chill slow down
she was like nah nah i was like yo chill
slow down she was like nah i was like
she was like why didn't you do that she
just ran in the corner
she was like why didn't you you're so
stupid why didn't you do that
i was like yeah because i still want to
keep going
that shuts it down that's probably tough
for jay-z when you think about it
oh my gosh probably shutting things down
for him yeah i mean that's the
i mean i wouldn't be turned i wouldn't
be turned off
a little tick of me elmo but shout out
to jay i love jay-z i love it i don't
have to say that he's not watching